[Music]
port county school district board of directors met on friday to
discuss violence in schools
how are you greetings cristian cásseres with
kirchner informative superego in
spanish i tell you that the board members have
already reached out about the recent
cases of  violence and bullying in
different schools throughout the valley
many parents have complained to the
district alleging that they do not protect
minors from these attacks and that they must
do something more to prevent the crystal
lovers of the kansas city chiefs
is out of prison  He posted
bail after being arrested for
allegedly being involved in a
beating prior to the 2022 football game.
Ramón Se stands accused of beating a
man leaving a nightclub
two weeks ago. The
New Orleans Saints player Young Chamber
also faces  charges for this
incident two others were
involved in this beating and were
found at and surrendered to him
Authorities earlier this week
got more information about a series
of robberies at various
ATMs belonging to
businesses throughout the valley. There is an incident
caught on camera in November that
shows a man strapping an
ATM to his truck
and then  he is seen driving breaking the
business near highway 215 and
breakbot the suspect as you can see
there on his screen is caguas 42 years old
says he did it because he had to pay
his bills he is accused of stealing 6
cms belonging to different businesses in
the valley  well it's due in court
next week and we close the week with
a really sunny day but don't put
your coat away yet temps
reaching 60 degrees will rise by the
weekend approaching 70 there will be
some winds by monday
temps will drop below  Hit for
next week with the highest listen to
this in the 50's I'm Cristian Cáceres with
his brief informati  vo de aficionado in
Spanish good day
[Music]